- This is probably the pettiest
and most vindictive
thing I have ever heard
in a legal context,
and it comes straight from Elon Musk.
Now Elon Musk's hatred of the SEC,
the Securities and Exchange
Commission, is well known.
Musk and the SEC have
butted heads many times,
but when one of Tesla's
outside law firms, Cooley,
which is one of the largest
law firms in the country,
hired a former lawyer for the SEC,
Elon Musk wasn't having it,
so he called up one of the
partners at this huge law firm
and said, "If you don't fire this lawyer,"
who has nothing to do with Tesla,
doesn't work on any of the Tesla cases
and whose only offense was that
he used to work for the SEC,
"If you don't fire him,
"I will fire the entire law firm
"and not let them work
with Tesla anymore."
I guess when you're worth $300 billion,
you can choose whatever
law firm that you want,
but apparently that lawyer,
who's just an associate,
not even a partner at the
law firm, still works there.
But man, Elon Musk, that is really petty
and that is really vindictive.